okay so this guy I mean this guy it  didn't really happen they thank God  didn't happen because this guy was like  a supermodel really good looking guy and  now I'm meeting this guy that was back  in Italy and I'm literally down the road  what are you wearing babe and he's  wearing something and this guy was so  ugly it was an old different person  right so you got catfish yeah I was like  sorry I cannot make it I just literally  run down the road see what men go  through every day  you will see me running down the road so  quick I was like I'm sorry I can't make  it running I was like speeding I was  like where are you I can see you going  somewhere I was like oh no that wasn't  me  it was so bad it was it was no it was  terrible  since then I was like never again